here to talk about the security being
put in place the threats in the
government is watching out for right now
is
douglas alevan he's a senior fellow at
the foreign policy research institute
and a former national security council
director
douglas can you give us some sense of
the conversations right now that are
going on
within the intelligence community
well the intelligence community is
focused outward so they're looking at
what our
external adversaries are doing about
this internally
law enforcement led by the fbi and the
the rest of the department of homeland
security
is doubtless having conversations with
the various state polices
and then certainly the local police
around each of the state capitals
probably focused on the places that have
been incidents before
richmond lansing salem oregon
douglas um there's so many threats on
social media right
on these different sites i wonder how is
it how is law enforcement distinguishing
between what is a genuine threat and
what's just an aspirational
threat well it's very difficult to parse
all these things look there are people
who are genuinely
upset about the results of the election
and who want to
protest that and that is their
constitutionally guaranteed
first amendment right then there are
those who want to use violence to
overthrow the result and that is
something entirely different
but figuring out who among those are
really serious
and who are just social media
impersonators you know people who are
trying to gain a reputation online and
you know wouldn't know which end of a
gun to point
is very very difficult for law
enforcement figuring out who's real and
who's just making noise
for that matter douglas uh with the eye
turn toward
domestic terrorism is there some concern
that foreign adversaries
might launch an attack on us on this
date
i don't think there's any real concern
about foreign adversaries i mean
certainly al qaeda would love to take
advantage of this but i think we have
them pretty well in a box at least
at the moment what foreign adversaries
are doing with this
is making hay in the information arena
the chinese for example are very much
out there saying hey you know you've got
people storming washington
don't criticize how we're handling hong
kong how we're handling the uyghur
problem
that's where our adversaries are really
taking advantage of this
douglas so much focus what happened on
january 6th and obviously the
inauguration coming up this wednesday
but these problems don't go away what is
the focus
as we move forward past the inauguration
look this could be a long-term problem
we clearly have a very
passionate minority that feels very
strongly
that they are utterly disenfranchised
they're in small communities of practice
where everyone believes this
they have a lot of guns they live mostly
in rural areas
law enforcement there may be sympathetic
to their views and so
isn't inclined to put a spotlight on
them or highlight that they're there
this could be a long-term problem going
forward
that is disturbing to hear douglas
oliven thank you so much